damn I didn't realize til you guys are
coming on but um in fact you know you're
in grudge match but it goes all the way
back that taxi driver and Rocky Top for
Oscars at the same time exactly and
actually there at the theaters right
next door to one another so I go out
there going hmm so I take pictures like
rocky bit like that but you like that on
the night do people know the rock was
walking a shoe in or no no it was
actually it was about four or five
elderly ladies with umbrellas were
trampling we had to get out of the
theater I mean it was like the first ten
minutes they go who is his greasy guy
crooked mouth and then eventually it
caught on it but it was not by any means
magic that first day it was a horror
because I was it was just some Hollywood
folklore but the the story about you not
giving them the script without agreeing
to you starring in it that that is true
oh yeah definitely it was just one of
those crossroad situations that every
artist faces early on go left go right
and if you make the wrong decision
sometimes regret it forever and I just
knew I had I wasn't a very good student
but I decided I was like understood
dialogue whatever so I wrote something I
know I could do that I could feel good
with and that could show everything that
is possible in my repertoire
this is well that's great but let's have
Brian on the old order let's have Burt
Reynolds do it or Robert Redford or so
they're bringing up all these bankable
names and I said no no I don't think so
and that time I was down that I'm gonna
had to sell my dog we'd have a food to
feed I said one of us doesn't eat they
to you my wife or the dog
was it so it was right one of those
things where you really roll the dice
and it paid off but it was a big long
shot because you talk about selling your
dog we've got a big boy we've got a
picture oh really
you have a picture of the dog he's at
the dog that's it you can see why I
couldn't feed him Buffalo it's a bull a
bull mastiff yeah that's a dog I don't
why even when I was totally broke I
always wanted to have an animal with me
and I mean literally I was as an usher
making 36 dollars a week that was it you
know and this dog that made
I don't eat that maybe all you eat the
dog there's one of these has a happy
ending I miss Doug it does so finally I
get the job I go back to the fellow I
sold it to who now won't give it back
and he's a very short guy really really
short and he's did he ride the dog piece
of furniture I mean he's literally is
the bed or something but he says so that
he paid me like 60 bucks or dog-eaters
I'll give me the dog bad for 3,000 I
don't have $3,000 he goes right I want
to be in the movie so I put him in the
movie yeah he's in first guy's little
scene he goes I'm walking it girls how'd
you do that I said I said I I did great
you should have been there he goes I go
well how'd you do I said what are you
deaf fingers no I'm short
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
you